[Applause]
Justice that's what Ralph yarls family
wants for the 16 year old who was shot
and injured last week yarl had
mistakenly rang the doorbell of Andrew
Lester's house in Kansas Missouri while
trying to pick up his younger brothers
Lester opened the door and fired on
Ralph yarl prosecutors have now charged
luster with two counts including first
degree assault which carries a life
sentence
continue to work
as with any serious case
we approached this one in an objective
and impartial manner
joining community members outside the
house where yarl was shot his family is
grateful that he is recovering
he is alive and he's healing
the case has outraged many across the
United States including the White House
President Joe Biden called yarls family
offering his support while vice
president Kamala Harris said on Twitter
no child should ever live in fear of
ringing the wrong doorbell the
prosecutor in this case has determined
the shooting was not in self-defense and
says it may have been racially motivated
my message the community
in Clay County
we enforce the laws and we follow the
laws and that does not matter where you
come from
or what you look like or how much money
you have
everyone is held to the same state there
have been rallies in the state
speaking out against gun violence and
demanding Justice for yarl many have
questioned why the suspect wasn't
arrested and charged immediately after
the shooting but for y'all's family they
say they're just happy to have him home
Al Jazeera